it's bueller's fifth start this year
he's giving up two earned runs or fewer
in each of the first four including last
time out against the padres
two runs over seven innings and the
strikeouts finally showed up he had a
season high nine of those and boy he
will not walk you so you're gonna have
to try and figure out a way to put him
in play and put it in play firmly to get
some runs off him five pitch mix this
guy's the full deal here and there's a
first pitch ambushed by jesse winker and
he rocks it to right for another home
run the longest hitting streak into
baseball continues on the very first
pitch big flies in three straight games
one nothing rinse i mentioned it walker
bueller in the first inning has given up
just one base hit in the four starts
that he's had before tonight with one
pinch well there's the second hit and it
was a big one and now nick castellanos
so it's start overtime for walker
bueller snapped a seven-game losing
streak though last night
bueller gets him to chase for the first
out tonight
walker bueller gets right back on the
saddle joey vado getting a start did not
start last night but came in as a pinch
hitter later on a one-two from buehler
votto swings at a face high
that is a rarity that is becoming more
common now the batter is mike mustakas
mostaka's flails and misses and three
straight strikeouts swinging after a
home run in the first pitch of the game
there is jeff hoffman he's out to his
best start ever i mean by winning two
games already he equaled his win total
for last year and the year before way
inside ball four back-to-back walks
and now the dodgers have a little
something brewing here with two outs
attacks gets the ball
in the air
gliding in naquin
makes the squeeze
a pair of two out walks stranded here's
alex glandino who hit leadoff last night
and
bueller's fourth k as he gets the
fastball by blandino arizona comes in
hop winning six of their last seven
that is a destroyed piece of lumber that
induces a weak little roller back to
bueller and a one two three second
gavin to battle bucks came back from the
il last night
swing of the miss oh nice pitch by
hoffman ben the knee gavin lux first k
of the day for hoffman
let me get on with two out so the
pitcher can come up
that is smoke to short mustaches on the
shift makes the pick the dealer gave up
a home run in the first pitch that he
threw he's retired six in a row since
and now gets ready for the
good third good afternoon good night
on three pitches now five k's
the pitcher hoffman great american
ballpark takes strike three two up and
two down
and now jesse winker and grounds one up
the middle seeger ranging to his left
and on seven pitches oh one two three
third for walker bueller who had 48 in
1980
turn the ball into a strike
nice pick by bottom
trying to go the other way votto playing
well off the bag
laid out to his right
and hauled it in for out number two
nick castellanos joey vado mike mustakas
against walker bueller one nothing reds
there castiganos gives a gift he smokes
a ball into the gap turns it first and
gallops onto second with a double a
breaking ball right there cassiano loves
the ball down and this one hung up there
a little bit for him it was about thigh
high but that's just a good swing a lead
off double and in scoring position for
joey votto
and there's the walk bravado one out and
now the reds with runners at second and
third
he's down swinging here big k for
buehler two dawn in the fourth walker is
just a different pitcher when he can
land the curve ball
seven k's tonight and it's up to
blandino with two out
with the cutter
gets out of the gym with his eighth
strikeout through four innings he's been
through the wear and tear and they they
can pick on a guy that might be a little
bit short on stuff lead off walk and the
tying run is aboard for max munson
back-to-back walks again for turner and
muncie
this time though they start the inning
against hoffman where all of a sudden
first and second no out you're getting
to the second half of your order and you
need to explode and will smith who's
coming up in that five spot flat out to
center field his first time at turner
and muncie aboard and is now one for 18
this year with runners in scoring
position that's another 1-2 flop
smith hammers
forget about it goodbye
it was just a matter of time will smith
with a home run and the dodgers lead it
3-1
boy did he clobber that
home run number three on the season for
smith he took the one-two pitch and sent
it long distance we talked about getting
a pitch that you would swing at in a
home run hitting contest
well he got it and he did it beyond
misreading that stack here once i leave
the studio
that's how you know you're really close
and that one's close on barnhart now the
reds have the lead off man on base for
the third time in five innings well the
batter is kyle farmer 2-1
and that is sky deep right center field
taylor who can't get to it off the wall
barnhart chugs through second he claims
third and farmer on his heels at top
second base as he thunders a double and
the reds have second and third nobody
out for the second straight inning
golden scoring opportunity here with
second and third and nobody out they've
changed the man who's gonna hit and now
tyler stevenson is going to hit runners
in scoring position hitting 500
sends this one up the middle
gobble flick onto first they concede the
run barnhart scores farmer to third rbi
ground out for tyler stevenson one run
game jesse winker after stevenson drives
in a run is going to see shifted infield
in
and he rips it in a right field base hit
tie game farmer scores
winker is smoking
all even at three boy waker not only has
a a really good eye going right now he
just has a really good understanding
what pitchers are trying to do to him
and nathan slaps a two-out single alex
blandino the second baseman struck out
swinging in the second did it again in
the fourth payoff pitch he struck him
out it matches a season high with his
9th k
chris taylor is over two tonight he
ground it out to short in the second
inning and then struck out
down the line unfair into the left field
corner from taylor smith read it well
and is bolton around third dino holds
him
a double from chris taylor that ball was
absolutely pummeled roger stadium usher
on the field did not know where to go
this ball just keeps chasing him okay
now what's the other one he's going to
get in the way this
[Music]
it was like a red shell on mario kart
smith the runner at third taylor at
second and matt beatty is at the plate
another one too
bouncing ball
dodgers lead matt batty comes through
a two run single and the dodgers lead
5-3 matt beatty comes through maybe
that'll get the baity going and now
tying run comes to the plate and kyle
farmer barnhart a decent lead off second
breaking ball hung a bit and it's
stunned to left center late break by
barnhart he's given the wave around
third trouble on the transfer by beatty
hard base hit for kyle farmer and an rbi
and the reds climb back within one it's
5-4 and here off the bench a eugenio
suarez the 1-2
breaking ball gets him looking and
walker mueller has his 10th strikeout
tonight good hand for walker bueller who
leaves with a 5-4 lead scott alexander
comes on the third diving stop by turner
gets it out of his glove they get one at
second and safe at first what a play by
turner they managed the front side out
two men away but turner absolutely stole
a base hit from winker
now runners at first and second base and
here's joey votto that'll ignite the
runners winker from second castellanos
from first they break and voto slugs it
into right field base hit winker center
round third he scores bets gathers
castellanos given the green light the
throw in cut off castellano scores
standing and a two-run double for joey
votto the reds on top six to five here
comes babe ruth that's right babe wink
he can really hit he slugs that one into
the right field corner another hit more
extra bases for winker a three-hit night
for the hottest man in major league
baseball reds will go to the bullpen and
they'll bring on the veteran
left-hander sean doolittle so muncie the
last hope for the dodgers one
and foul ground makes the catch
doolittle slams the door and the reds
have claimed the series